oh hello I didn't see you there I was
just having a moment with my stuffed
animals I've had these guys since I was
a little ghoul just whispering sweet
satanic chants into their ears at night
until I'd fall asleep oh middle school
here's a story do you want to hear the
one about the guy who learns that having
a dead girlfriend has its benefits I bet
you do
you
so do you just start asking a question
if I don't want to start from the
beginning okay so this happened a few
weeks ago I stumbled across this
memorial page for Emily which kind of
hurt Emily was great but she is kind of
dead right exactly so it's like it's
like pretty much over
here is the even weirder part Emily and
I used to say that exact thing to each
other all the time like it's kind of our
thing saying hello to each other was
your thing right exactly and that's all
she sent that night over the next few
days I kept doing these notifications
that Emily was tagging herself and
recent pictures of mine but the tags
kept showing up in pictures that Emily
wasn't in but she would have been in
them if she hadn't died right hey listen
could you make me stop like interrupting
me so much so I log on to Emily's
account try to change the password to
stop whoever's pranking me
but of course it doesn't stop
and then Emily finally said something
other than hello yeah what yeah why are
you doing this I'm gonna stop you right
there you know what's wrong with me
No but our time is up really
all right whatever dude fine
just helping people perfect
oh so sweet and I still love you
isn't that crazy you know what they say
better to have loved and lost and then
pretend to be what you lost so that you
don't have to admit your promise
isn't denial great it's my favorite
stage of grief especially when it
involves death isn't that right mr.
awesome
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe if you
still have fingers and if you do can I
borrow them I promise to give them right
back and be sure to follow us on Twitter
if you know what's good for you I think
they made a mistake maybe I should just
go back to the door
vamps are real they own Morganville but
you're safe with us